garrett son from the jobless gamers and
the one thing I'm most excited for of
course coming with the heist dlc it's
not only the money payouts but if things
come with free mode the daily objectives
and of course the adversary modes rocks
are recently announced for the same rate
I'm really really excited to see exactly
what's come with the free mode hey it's
ross or mr. boss to the win and the most
things I'm excited about for Heights is
the new vehicles rockstar said that
they're gonna be bringing back vehicles
from previous gtas we're going to be
seeing vehicles like the Hydra which of
course is a vertical takeoff and landing
jet also motorcycles bikes planes cars
it's going to be really exciting and you
can use your money that you get in hice
and actually buy them in free mode so
that's really cool I can't wait to get
hice earn money and of course get those
new vehicles and all the new cars so I'm
very excited about that
the one of the most excited about for
heists to do with my friends is there's
one mission in particular where you have
to go onto a Navy ship and infiltrated
be stealthy and you gotta take over and
get a new vehicle called the Hydra and
it looks really fun and according to
what rockstar has put out we're gonna be
battling a bunch of military guys and
it's going to be a fun challenge
especially on the difficulty modes that
they have implemented into the game so
for heist I'm looking forward to playing
with my friends you see I'm a loner
right so this gives you an opportunity
to be able to spread my wings and put
with other people in the online
community decay the eight people that I
regularly play with known as the crew